thank you everybody it's a really good
turnout for you know one of the first
panels of the whole of show welcome to
pax obviously it's the very beginning of
a very fun weekend look I think one of
the really big things that I want to
touch on and also welcome to people
watching online this is one of the
streamed theaters so I always got to
give the acknowledgement to the people
who are watching out there one of the
really big things that I wanted to kind
of talk about here today was you know I
don't make trailers I love to watch
trailers I think they are obviously
incredibly important to the business
these days we have very kind of online
video sort of world so I think we know
that as people who love games we want to
get a sense of what a game is going to
play like or if not even play like
what's it gonna feel like to go and kind
of spend hours in this in this world and
is it enough to convince us to part with
our very precious dollars so I got
together a panel of people who really
kind of know the ins and outs both
makers of trailers and marketers to
really help us understand what makes a
good trailer what is their perspective
on how important trailers are in this
business today and then how do you make
something that balances the excitement
and grabs people's attention but tries
to not go too far and promise too much
so that you end up disappointing people
so our fabulous panel here today is we
have Mick Hamel who's the head of
production at the CG studio and trailer
making studio plastic wax we have Chris
Wright the argon let's let's give
everybody the clap as we go down Dahlia
we have Chris Wright managing director
of a publisher and company
surprise-attack
shrink Custis who is the co-founder and
director of league of geeks who you may
know best for their game our Miller and
Katie Staggs a creative director and
consultant from the company luma
consulting so I I generally like to you
know Skippy let's have everybody's
five-minute background history type
stuff and instead try to dive into just
I think a good question that everybody
can have a quick buy that which is from
each of your perspectives because each
are quite different
how important are trailers to your
business and I guess to the whole games
business from from where you sit and
start with the pre-rendered or in engine
trails for the game so and without that
we would not have a company so that's
great but just in terms of how important
they are to gaming in the industry in
general I mean I think a really great
trailer is what is going to put a game
on the map and in the in the forefront
and eyes of the players you know as soon
as possible and as early as possible you
know might be you know like it could be
three years out from when the game comes
out as a teaser that gets people to go
holy [ __ ] that looks awesome like you
know say the cyberpunk 2077 trailer for
example that it runs like oh my god
when's this game coming out so yeah it's
extremely important and yeah that's
pretty much cool great yes Emily so on
the the indie spectrum the trailer is
probably the single most important
marketing asset it's the thing that gets
a journalist to write about the game
because they'll watch the trailer after
hopefully reading the pitch it's the
thing that gets the consumer to
understand what the game is we don't
have that long lead-up where gamers are
like hungry for information but they
will be on the triple-a so the trailer
is like your chance to get in front of
them for two minutes and and sell the
games are yeah
it's Verizon's like the most important
thing when we're thinking about
marketing assets or marketing messages
is the trailer is kind of like where it
where it starts cool
Trent yeah I would I would completely
agree I mean we announced our game our
mellow with a fully animated trailer I
mean we were we didn't even we weren't
getting paid for our work and we put
like 10 or $15,000 into a trailer which
was the biggest expense so far and we
didn't even have a game at that boy well
it's gonna be hey I was just saying tone
but yeah it's huge for independent
developers I think as well for a game
like ours which is largely pretty
abstract I mean it's a strategy game
with like characters moving around hex
tiles so you know you can show someone a
hundred foot rabbit standing on a you
know on a tiny forest or you can give
them a fully animated trailer it sells a
lot more and also I think the biggest
one for us is that if we're trying to
get press like obviously Chris's touch
on a few things like you've got it it
said it's important to get this sell the
quick two minutes he'll put it in front
of people's eyes who wouldn't normally
be looking for that sort of thing but
when dealing with the press if you can
give them something that we call like a
premium asset which is a video content
so you send them a press release and
you're like hey we've just announced our
game it's really cool here's a screen
shot they're like okay well I am what am
I gonna do write an article and just put
up a screen shot but if you can give
them a trailer then it's nice rich
content but they know that a lot of
their viewers or readers are going to
probably want to engage with and it's
it's just better for the side in general
so that's a bits a big one for us it
helps us get a lot of press and we've
done I was going through our final
trailer folders and we've done I think
almost like 10 trailers for various
reasons throughout our milos lifespan
from my perspective in marketing the
trailer is the first point where you can
connect the emotion of your games to
your potential audience so I I really
like them because I just think that
they're the first opportunity that a
developer has to like tell a part of
their story and start building that
community out there and get people
invested and as you've already said
they're one of the best marketing assets
that we can have and I always try and
squeeze more trailers out of the people
that I work with because they're so
effective when it comes to just building
hype and like getting excitement and
representing what potentially people
could have a have a piece
eventually that's really I mean it's
something I guess that we can under
appreciate sometimes but you know
obviously the big triple-a guys have so
many different angles that they can hit
on with marketing budget but for a lot
of the smaller guys that actually yeah
having the trailer is the absolute
that's essentially your one-stop way to
get people's attention is that is that
really kind of right trend yeah it
really is and I guess it's just like
it's hard to pitch a game like I know
Indies that we'll be talking to each
other and seeing each other it shows and
still three years down the road like
having exhibited their game and maybe
developing it we're still they're still
talking about you know I'm hearing their
pitch evolve and we're like picking it
apart I've been on huge long email
threads with other Indies where people
are talking about you know the anatomy
of a pitch like how do you get that
elevator pitch down and that's
essentially what a trailer is like it's
just so important a we from the like I
said from the beginning of development
we've been sinking so much money into
trailers just because like they're
incredibly shareable and they just they
get it across like it's your you have
you know video audio you know you can
show the game that you can overlay text
like whatever it is it's such a
fantastic toolkit to be able to pitch a
game just pin someone down for two
minutes and just give me two minutes of
your life and this is slightly different
angle from that I think the trailer is
also an awesome way to get tone across
and then that may not necessarily mean
like selling your features or like
saying specifically what the gameplay is
or what it's like but selling like that
emotional journey and like that
excitement and I think like there's some
really successful examples of trailers
like some of the Stanley parable
trailers that do that they sell that
time without even like showing any of
the actual content of the games Jeff
found really fascinating so we did that
with a mellow with the debut trailer so
our first trailer was fully animated so
2d animations slow we kind of and it's
funny we the people that we look for
would like direct or look towards like
directors like Terrence Malick and stuff
we just wanted this sort of visual
tapestry that sold a tone to the players
we wanted them to get into the world of
our mellow and buy into the experience
and the fantasy as opposed to being like
10 map
eight characters you know we do that
with our launch trailer as you're saying
Katie because it came up as you're all
walking in she said oh do you get sick
of watching your trailers and I said
well no because we're really proud of
him but this one is a little bit more
sell than we would usually have because
it is a launch trailer you've got a hype
it up a bit you've got to like you know
talk about the features a little bit
more but yeah we we definitely did the
fully animated 2d thing selling the tone
of the world so that we could preload
players with like the the feel of the
universe and everything for sure it's
increasing I'm on this kind of same
point but I'm curious as part of your
answer how long do you sort of you know
encourage the Indies that you guys work
with how long should they be spending on
trying to you know get that trailer
right while also maybe it's a you know
one or two person shop sometimes that
they're like I'm just I'm trying to make
a game here and you like make a good
well as the publisher we do the trailer
so part of our work so sometimes the dev
will edit it and now actually
increasingly rare circumstances but it
is a lot of time and also that's where
we've been our expertise in so so we
managed to trailer so earlier on the
hack net and the oil trailers play which
is probably two of our best efforts we
spend a lot of time on those but the dev
doesn't have to you know spend a lot of
that hours they're just involved
involved for it yeah yeah it is it is a
unique skill any of these it is hard and
it does take a lot of time and strategy
and thinking about the game in a
different way and to Katie's point
earlier like the trailer sells the
feeling it sells the benefits not the
features you know advertising 101 and a
lot of indie trailers fall into that
trap of like I'm just gonna show the
gameplay and I'm gonna keep coming up
with feature cards about what's in the
game and it's like that doesn't sell
like ultimately what you get out of
playing in the game yeah you know you
have to sell the feeling yes you need to
explain the game and so often if we have
a very tonal video we will often do like
a gameplay video to go on the store as
like a secondary thing you know for
screen cheat we did that for example we
have a habit of signing games that are
impossible to try and like it's the kind
of become a thing but then we actually
produce trailers
love so I'm kind of really proud of that
but the hack net screen chick and all
while are very very hard games just to
show the gameplay and I think that
actually worked well for us and it
forced us to to really think about
actually how are we going to illustrate
the pitch without relying on gameplay
footage to to do that
yeah you've work with you know we as
we're coming in we said played a few
things but from you know injustice to
trailer from e3 this year at the Civ six
launch trailer which interesting I
always find the launch trailers these
days typically are then the you know the
cinematic you see when you first load up
the game but you know when you're
talking about these kind of very
triple-a sort of all things how long do
you guys spend working on it and then
also you know what's the relationship
between the the developers and then your
work sort of on on that trailer it might
be sort of quite separate at times but
obviously there needs to be a lot of
back and forth yeah sure um
so typically probably a maybe two to
three minute trailer will take us about
12 to 16 weeks depending on how crazy
our clients schedules are the the lego
star wars force awakens trailer that you
were showing up there we did in some
obscene the tight amount of time was
like eight weeks or something crazy but
uh in regards to you know the the
connection with the developers for
example I mean we tend to have two types
of projects sometimes they'll be in a
jam our contagion see in the middle and
they'll sort of pitch something to the
end client he's with the probably the
the publisher and they'll come to us or
sometimes the developers come to us
directly as in the case would say
something like c6 so we were just
working directly with with 2k because
they you know didn't it wasn't that
trailers you said it wasn't really a
marketing piece per se it was you know
sort of encapsulating the energy and
vibe of the game for the very first time
you open up and play it but well in the
way of you know marketing agencies go
we're gonna create this specifically to
you know
crease you know the viewership and
players who will download the game but
from the perspective of 2k it's a it's
it's its main focus is storytelling
piece for like it's an in-game cinematic
in a way that has a secondary purpose of
you know being getting get getting the
t's out there you know the week before
the game comes out and now I noticed as
well with a couple of things we showed
from plastic wax that you know there's
something like the force awakens lego
trailer like dude did you guys generate
all of the assets for that or was it
sort of some of the clips pulled from
the game itself whereas say injustice
and see if that seems like it might be a
lot more of your kind of original
animation work so in that in regards to
the Lego force awakens trailer and we
built everything in that brick by brick
yeah right like the if you actually look
at the environments in the background
there little Lego pretty stacked onto
one on top of one another and we get we
get sort of low res game assets I know
if you're familiar with any of the Lego
games you know they're you know they're
not like you know photo real quality
they're they look great and they've got
a nice shading the lighting stuff but
when you want to look at them really
closely actually our guys go in and
actually etch in like we will buy it all
they go minifigs and take like high-res
photos of them and they'll H in the
seems there's a there's I'm just
entertaining for a moment we did a
trailer for Lego dimensions we had a
LEGO version of Gandalf and there's one
shot where you can see his leg from
behind and if you look really closely at
inside the back of the LEGO League
there's a little hole there's an L and R
but the guys actually put in because
that's on the actual toys well you know
yeah we do get game assets but there's a
kind of into those to really make them
shine and pop this might be a little bit
of a tangent but they the Lego crew like
especially at Animal Logic and stuff
like that they have actual tools to just
build those assets using is a called
Lego design or
like that did you have access to any of
lego specific like moviemaking tools we
the guys do use Lego designers sometimes
yeah but we actually made some of our
own sort of procedural tools too
and we're doing a talk on it this
afternoon actually we're gonna go into
it if anyone's keen but you can select
the library of bricks and give it and it
will sort of intelligently fashion but
we definitely found that by time I just
want that yeah yeah we didn't have the
budget of animal watching so I think we
we kind of touched on a few of these
areas that I wanted to think about next
but if we kind of talk about a few of
those like very specific elements that
can help to kind of build the by but for
I think again we've talked about yeah
this gameplay trailers there's sort of
teaser trailers there's I guess the kind
of I'd know is that a difference between
like a sizzle reel and a teaser or is
that much the same thing but I'm not
sure if I'm kind of missing any of the
other types of trailers that might sort
of come along but you know music and
like style and all these kinds of things
like how what do you think is some of
those really sort of key things that
that maybe you know some companies kind
of overlook in terms of really kind of
nailing that that polish when they're
really trying to you know get
everybody's attention
I mean one thing is like non-game assets
yeah right so stuff that you're creating
so like we've hacked that it was very
simple which if we just did some text in
between but in the style of the game but
that made a big difference because we
were able to create content which is
purely a trailer we've all well we we
hired a guy called Marlon Weber who is a
which one like the two top indie game
trailer guys and he who took our
direction but he then executed that with
all the fake desktop stuff in the game
and that was all created from scratch
and a lot of work went into there and
then enabled us a ton of story that
wasn't reliant on their game assets so I
guess even at the triple-a and it's the
same thing when you're building assets
for the trailer that isn't just like hey
we got all this amazing content you know
and yeah I think the biggest problem is
is getting stuck we have like what have
I got in the game to show
now and then limiting yourself to that
yeah because often it's like I'm saying
the first or melodrama
that we were working on that actually
done announcer I'd be worked on that way
back in the day the game at that point
didn't look that great I pad and
whatever and not something you could
show yeah try to announce with that it
would not have been as impressive right
so yeah I think it's that like not being
limited by what's in the game but
starting from the point of view what
have I got to say and then what do I
need to do that and being prepared to go
outside of the but easy content to
achieve that it's standing at two so
there's actually um if from those you
ban games in Boston just recently made a
tool called six second steam trailers or
something like that I'd believe it's a
twitter twitter bot that you can follow
and what it does is it scrapes data from
steam and makes a supercut six second
trailer of every game that's released on
Steam so as soon as the game goes up on
Steam this Twitter bot will then make a
trailer where it grows like a second
from like six seconds from the trailer
and then we'll put it up on on like
tweet it out and say the name of the
game and you watch that and just games
are coming through you know 16,000 games
released all the time or whatever on
Steam but the thing is you look at it
and it's just a great point or example
of the saturation of the market and so a
big thing for us was how do we stand out
we are relative know like people knew
who we were in the Australian game
they've seen that that's five percent of
the market we need to be big in the
States and in Western Europe and in Asia
if we want to be super successful so how
do we stand out in a sea of not just
Indies but developers when people you
know spoilt for choice in games and so
you look at where you can come in a way
you can do that and so one of the people
that we worked with Adam Duncan who's
now at the studio
he worked he's worked in film and
animation he was at Animal Logic on the
Lego films and he's a you know being a
to traditional 2d illustrator and
animator
and so we teamed up with him and his
animation studio at the time to do fully
animated
2d trailer and like when when do you see
that you know I think maybe clay are the
only other ones that do that and then
also not making it like
all of this bombast and like hey buy the
game but making it a really slow
sentimental piece like just selling the
tone and like putting up some text being
a bit cryptic about you know heroes
being out on a journey really sell this
fantasy of you know hero's journey like
those those more emotional moments of
Lord of the Rings or Game of Thrones and
stuff like that and then music is a big
one as well we worked with lisa gerrard
who's an academy award-winning film
composer and singer songwriter and then
also how composer for the game was
historically from film as well Michael
Allen and those two put together the
most incredible soundtrack for our game
but we have all of our trailers scored
custom so we don't use assets from the
game for our trailers I think maybe the
launch trailer was the only one that we
did and but even then we never took time
to do that so we went to the people who
do the Game of Thrones trailers and we
said do our trailer and just paid them
so it's how do you stand out like
finding those things and so we made very
very specific decisions some that were
practical you know we can't show the
game so what else do we do that led us
to having a trailer that when we
released it like got covered by all the
major sites and got you know 100,000
views or whatever it was I'm just from
relative nobody's out of Melbourne
Australia Utah like just a just a second
ago but something that I see developers
always forgetting about and I feel I
have to remind them often is pacing and
how important pacing is for setting a
tone or setting a mood and I saw
something recently maybe you guys who
here has seen every frame a painting by
Tony Zhu couple you okay good for all
the rest of you I am so excited for you
because you didn't go and like check it
out now it's so good so Tony Zhu is this
like film critic he makes YouTube videos
and he like focuses on a particular an
angle of cinematography and one of the
recent ones I was watching he talked
about pace and he used the example of
Luke Skywalker and that like classic
scene where he's trying for the first
time to use the force to lift up his
ship out of the water do you guys
remember that one and he shows like a
breakdown of the amount of seconds
leading up to and after failure so how
long was the shot held beforehand so
like the build-up you think like
everyone's getting behind him you
reading for him he's gonna like he's
totally gonna do it
and then he fails and then that's the
key moment so that moment is held for
longer so it actually goes 3 to 1 in
terms of seconds and then 5 4 3 2 1 so
they hold the emotional moment much
longer than they hold that build-up and
it really creates like that sense of
failure and loss and that's the moment
that you're supposed to remember in the
film and so I think it's a really good
way for I think Tony does a particularly
good job of breaking down why pace is so
important and I like seeing I like to
check trailers that I'm working on
whether or not they have those that pace
and whether or not those pick those key
moments that we want people to remember
in the trailers are being held for the
right amount of time for you two guys
that are in the marketing side like are
there sometimes clients that you know
don't sort of see the importance or like
yeah do you find it's hard to convince
people sometimes to really put that
effort in or or do you think if someone
nowadays have been making game they know
how important the trailer is going to be
because it's such a lot of resources for
them and it's often money and time that
they don't have so yeah it is sometimes
hard but it's like I have to sit him
down and say look you know this is super
important you need to prioritize it and
often they don't have the skills
necessary for it as well it's a whole
other area of you know skills that
people build up over a lifetime and
they're now expected to be able to do
that so I often say like prioritize your
outsourcing and Trent I think you guys
are a wonderful example of how much
return you can get from that investment
even if they don't see it up front so
yeah it taunts you a question I do
sometimes have to do that yeah as a dev
I can 100% say that especially an indie
dev you're watching rushing towards
launch or these external deadlines are
stuff you're just looking for any excuse
to cut anything from your to-do list
yeah so if you can like justify in your
mind at all what okay so I'm sitting on
this panel and while we were like you
know just having little chats I tuned
out for a second I literally thought I
had this exact thought I wonder if we
could get away with not doing a trailer
for that next year I thought that we've
got somebody else there coming out and
I'm like is it big enough
will it just fire so you're definitely
thinking about it and yeah we've reached
points like we actually got to the point
with our launch trailer where we were
just like we're past the period where we
can get it done ourselves
and we have so many other things and
moving up to the launch of the game that
we've worked on for five years I mean
here we have ten people in the studio
like this is make or break our time
although we might be getting paid 80
bucks an hour or something like that on
the books it's worth paying someone $500
an hour to do what we could probably do
because our time is so much more
valuable right now and so like I said we
just went out and to the Game of Thrones
crew I think a little interesting
tangent - as you mentioned Marlon Weber
this whole ended everything like with
Indies everywhere it's really
interesting but you don't see the people
on the sidelines that are also Indies
that so like Kurt Gartner and Derrick
Lou and Marlon Weber these are all way
all of those indie trailers that you see
out all the time like even things like
Campo Santo is trailer for fire watch
and you know towerfall all these -
everyone's a lot of them aren't done by
the studio they're done by one of five
of these and he like dancing is here
trailer gunslingers that I just cruising
around doing amazing work on the scene
servicing a little bit new studios a lot
of good games get killed by a bad
trailer it's we were working well we
were hoping the sign again that we
didn't get in the end but the dev was
super nice and so he kept in kept in
touch and he decides to a Kickstarter
and he was gonna do it himself and he
didn't get any help from the publisher
in the end that he went with cuz he
wanted to do it himself
and this was a game that had every big
youtuber playing it like millions and
millions of views it was super hot game
and he put out a terrible trailer and
just scraped over 30,000 dollars on
Kickstarter he should have made ten
times that with the base that he had but
he destroyed the trailers just terrible
that's because he was trying to do it
all himself and taking it on and maybe
didn't realize just how much was
involved and that's really painful when
you see again it's got a great pitch in
it but it has been pitched in a really
bad way because you see just that lost
lost potential so yeah I think they
sometimes devs don't don't quite
understand how much of a difference it
can make to your your potential and how
much you can screw yourself over if you
don't invest in it
yeah just on that note I mean we've
sometimes even the relationship between
marketing and the dev can be super
damaging particularly if they if they
sort of I know it sounds bad if they
collaborate too much we had this trailer
that was unfortunately sort of cancelled
and I'm telling you it's the best IP or
that you could ever imagine working on
as a dream project we started off with a
great pitch our clients in the book in
the boardroom guys it's amazing you know
and then six to eight weeks down the
road you know the the problem starts to
surface they're they're getting you know
the marketing guys like oh you have to
show this feature and this feature in
this feature and that's up you know
changing the script and the flow and
then they just send it off to the sorry
they send that they send it to the
developer in another country and go hey
guys what do you think three months in
to this you know three pro production
and then they come back with all these
feedback like oh no you can't do that
you've got to change that and it can be
it can be really destructive and it
takes actually either it's really great
when either the developer or the
marketer just has a really strong clear
vision and they stick to it they don't
start you know listening to the you know
the cleaning lady who goes past the
office and go what do you think about
this and she's like oh you know he's a
different boy danger of like too many
edits as well like we nearly ruined the
Orwell trailer near the end because it
just wasn't quite right and so we
literally we were like for 72 hours
moderns on the east coast of North
America so the time difference was
terrible but at all hours of the night
and so on we were emailing backwards and
forwards and making his slight that all
changes to the point where we almost
couldn't tell anymore like was it good
or not and in the end we managed to get
the right balance but it is like at that
final point or if there's too many
voices coming here it is so such a
dangerous point in the life of the
trailer where you can over edit it to
the point of just lose his dad you know
that flower the magic that it kind of
had it won't point even when it was
rough so yeah it is a danger and keeping
it tight to that group that's gonna it's
make the decisions is really important
yeah it's real bad a scientist Oh crisis
it's a real balance between like the
high level maintaining the high levels
selling the dream like selling the
sizzle not the sausage so we had a very
successful Kickstarter campaign and one
of the reasons that I believe it's four
is because we just want a hundred
percent understood that kick-start is
about selling the dream it's like it's
not about listing your features or
whatever its selling people what their
what they're missing out on like you
know all that and that's the same for
our trailers and I think keeping that
real bird's-eye view where we actually
do get into the point where we've got
like five different edits and I like I'm
like the kings intonation on that war
it's like maybe a bit better than this
and I'm asking other people in there
like but like we do get to that point
but then you've sort of got to step back
and go okay you know what that doesn't
really matter what matters is that we're
selling the dream we're selling this
sizzle and I think you know without
trying to get into that whole
conversation that's something that no
man's sky was absolutely fantastic at
like you can't argue with the fact that
it was like the most solid greatest
pitch like in video in video game like
recent history it's like they just knew
how to sell that game and like all the
trailers everything like they understood
the high level what is our fantasy what
is our play of fantasy what are we
selling and I think all of the issues
you know that came after that with them
you know we're just more of like how
they manage the PR and how they like you
have the interviews went and stuff like
that not clarifying particular things
but that general high-level pitch of the
game is super strong and I think if you
can nail that what no man sky's a
perfect example of how big it can be
darkest dungeon is another one Firewatch
is another one like these trailers you
know it's Star Wars though the trailers
for Star Wars I mean I've been watching
that series since I was like a child now
new trailer comes out and like tingles
all throughout my entire audience like
sign me up
and that's actually yeah it kind of
leads in nicely they're in when you're
having that first back and forth they'd
love to kind of have an understanding of
you know when they come to you are they
saying you know he's the he's the vibe
we're looking for or is it that you go
back and sort of say okay based on what
we've seen he is he is what we think we
can build for you as a as a vibe for a
trailer yeah it kind of happened
both ways sometimes the client will come
to us with a pretty clear idea in a
script and other times where we hear
about the project and we'll pitch on it
so in the case of the the Lego Star Wars
Force awakens trailer we heard about
that and we and at that time the only
piece of media that was out for the
force awakens was that first teaser and
we just said let's make that with Lego
and and seriously when we created we
basically went in and made these style
frames in CG that were recreating
specific frames from from the trailer
itself just entirely out of Lego and
just sent them to the client and then
about a month later they came back to us
with the script which was that idea and
that was cool and I mean I just have to
say because it's super cool but on that
project the the final sign-off was JJ
alright and so we would just be walking
around the office we're totally delayed
it's like they haven't approved and
we're like are we're just waiting for JJ
so I think we're gonna take some
questions in a few minutes so if anybody
does sort of have any key questions you
can kind of head towards the mics and
we'll start that but that's probably
just a couple of minutes from now so get
your cool question thinking underway
what do you think people like me
everybody here in the room what do you
think fans and audiences don't really
understand about making it making a
trailer genuinely good or is there
anything or you know is it just
everything we've already talked about
yeah people want gameplay like every
trailer that we put out so we spoken
about a game publicly for like two years
even showed it off an exhibit at places
before we put any footage of gameplay on
it and people always like show me the
gameplay show me the gameplay like
doesn't matter at all like does not
matter you'll see it at some point like
will release gameplay yeah sure if you
launch a game and all you've shown your
CG like cinema intros it's a bit it's a
bit rough how do people know what the
gameplays about but like it's just
totally not about that that early
in the process that's a good question to
be getting I guess if people are
desperately keen to see yeah yeah
exactly like we just like some other
people on the team will be like oh we're
gonna do a gameplay thing I'm like no
this is this is actually exactly what we
want we want people hungry for that
gameplay I think like the conspiracy
theories that come out of trailers are
just hilarious like especially early
trailers when the game might still be in
development and you know why didn't they
put this in there oh what's gonna happen
you know and you're like it's not even
made yet like that but most of the time
like if you're watching a trailer and
you're wondering you know why elements
may be missing there's probably reason
for that and it could be as simple as
it's just not made yet or it could be as
simple as like the next one's gonna show
it and they're trying to build up to
something like any Easter rigging stuff
go on in the truck you know cuz they
under people men like people get frame
by frame through this stuff sometimes
and heaps in the oil trail out there
it's almost entirely mr. robot
references you can like freeze-frame it
and there's like this because there's
there's fake desktop staffs today's like
what's in his Twitter feed or straight
Twitter feed and it's almost all random
references to 1984 mr. robot and we put
he to that stuff in yeah
and then we created a Twitter account
for the character in the trailer as well
and we didn't know if people were gonna
respond to that or not some people found
it but it wasn't a big thing so we just
left that yeah people had responded we
were gonna like then create a whole like
human tweeting about staff when they're
building a following so yeah we just we
just made the effort because I had a
Twitter handle we were like someone's
gonna go look and it would be cool if it
was there yeah so that was fun he's kind
of like nice in the creative process to
do that kind of stuff yeah we had in the
Lego Star Wars trailer we actually had
at one point in the desert there was a
skeleton of Jar Jar Binks and but uh
unfortunately they were like no charge
we I the way that I write is not like
Georgia
you know you know everything that's it's
closed box quote um but I mean in
regards to like writing style and how
much you know about your universe it
actually drives my business partner and
like and creative partner blank crazy
cuz he's like what's the political
system of this race though I'm like I
don't know whatever you want to say and
so what I'm getting at is we will put
things in our trailer or in the game and
just make references to think so I did I
did a hero background on one of the
characters it's like from the Bandit
clan and I spoke about something like
the black yes II I kind of remember it's
like the the the Black Rose plot or
something like that and like what's that
and I will figure out we need some new
content or something it'll be the Black
Rose plot DLC so we do a lot of that
stuff like we'll just throw things in
there and create characters and you know
like these particular cutthroat highway
men that are robbing you it and that's
just sort of stuff that people always
ask us like who's that character what do
they do or like the black of the plot
Rose plot like oh my god what's that and
you know and then you see it into
fanfiction someone wrote a 70 page comic
like wrote and drew and everything a 70
page comic totally fanfiction on
Amalekites here yeah and that sort of
stuff finds its way into it it's amazing
like you just put out little little
crumbs and it gives you so many ways to
go with your with your stuff and for
other people to latch onto and create
engagement you know about the hand thing
one last question before you throw it
open how do you actually judge the
success of a trailer yeah is it just you
know it got this many views or are there
like sentiment tracking like what kinds
of things particular I guess from the
marketers you know what sorts of things
are you doing to really judge are we
building the right attention we need all
that sort of thing
things that we look for we judge all of
our PR campaigns by the number of
trailer views we get because it's the
most accurate way to tell so let's say
we get an article on seen it or GameSpot
that's great hey we're on GameSpot but
what we actually need to know is did it
actually engage people and do people
look at the article right and the
trailer views tell us there and we know
where the trial abused come from so we
have a successful announce you know
we're looking at like forty fifty
thousand views on the trailer and we're
like okay yeah that actually caught the
imagination so we certainly look at
views because almost all of those are
gonna be based on you know media
coverage rather than pure YouTube videos
we look at comments and we look at view
time so you can see on a youtube video
like whether people stay or not which is
why most trainers need to be under a
minute because after a minute it really
starts to drop down to like thirty forty
percent of the views of actually all the
way through but you can see if a trailer
is like dropping heavily after like 20
30 seconds the people just didn't engage
of it well if it stays really high all
the way through then then clearly like
people who were watching were we're
interested to watch more so we can look
at those um the last one is just balance
like if people are actually sharing the
trailer on Twitter then we've definitely
done our job because we that's critical
is that sense of like watch this you
need to see it - yeah that's a big
metrically you look at his number of
shares on Facebook another good one is
say for example if you're developing you
have a game released on Steam you can
tell where people are coming to your
page from the same for Kickstarter
things like that so and even more so if
it's your own website or something you
can put a bitly link on things so if you
have a bitly account um you know for
shortened URLs you can actually get
analytics on where people are used
coming from with that actual bitly link
or when they're using it so you know if
you're putting trailer up on youtube you
make a custom bitly link so you know if
people come to your site from that
length and it's obviously but you g1 so
we do that because we use views to it's
very accurate and it's also good to see
them like for a company like you but
then also it's like it's cool of people
who are watching your trailer but are
they watching it for 10 seconds and then
bouncing off to you know so how close
are they getting to the point of action
whether it be with a wish listing or
buying your game and so we try and track
that as much as possible like we will as
soon
you pop up into the all I've engaged
with anything armello we are looking at
everything that you've done down the
chain so like where are you going down
you're going to the website you're going
to the same page what are our
conversions on our steam page so what
percentage chance have we had of you
buying it etcetera and I think maybe
that's something about trailers that
people don't know is like how much we
use them to actually track like the
engagement of our games cool awesome
let's take a first question over here on
the on the lift so yeah that's really
tricky I guess the thing is that you
could if you feel confident you could
make it yourself like if there's enough
tools and everything out there if you
can make a game you can certainly make a
trailer like I'm not saying that you
have the creative ability to make a
great trailer but technically you can
make a trailer so I would you know even
if it's just in iMovie or something like
that right so you can that's the that's
one option
then there's always mates rates find a
friend who does this sort of stuff in
their day job and say like hey can you
help us out or but obviously with
respect to their craft and everything
and the fact that you're asking them to
do their job a little bit cheaper than
usual i but we found ways around it so
say for example that trailer was ten to
fifteen thousand dollars but it's a
minute thirty of fully 2d hand-drawn
animation and I mean cheap which is
cheap like that costs a thousand dollars
a second like if you go to someone like
ten Mouse in LA who you know do bunch of
cartoons and stuff like that they did
the Diablo shorts they will charge you a
thousand dollars a second so that's
really cheap but the way that we did it
was that Adam was part of the team he
was financially invested in the team his
studio was at a point where they wanted
a big project that wasn't just like an
ABC after-school kids cartoon that they
could play with there were two studios
this is getting is a lot of detail
anyway they wanted to relaunch their
brand and they thought that it was a way
that they could do it and it worked so
finding people who it's mutually
beneficial for to do
something cool to do a trailer with the
other thing is that the film film Vik
Victorian government have something
which is Chris and surprises a can
ourselves or we were some of the first
ones to take advantage of this and get
it into place they have a marketing fund
so if you have an independent game you
can apply for not production funds but
up to $30,000 in marketing funds so I'm
not sure if you're from Victoria but if
you're from Victoria well I'm sorry um
but anyway there are other ways that you
can do it
trailers yeah the cost is it's heavily
dependent on how much non-game stuff you
have to create and the quality of the
editor and so on but if you're releasing
an indie game commercially yeah and you
under invest in your trailer ever that's
time or dollars it's like it's the worst
thing to under invest in and all the
marketing like don't come and exhibitors
show like this if it means that you then
have the budget to spend two three grand
on a trail yeah because it's it really
makes such a big difference and every
part of the process in terms of someone
engaging not just press but also when
they come to the store page the first
thing they do is watch the trailer you
know it is the worst thing to to rush
out and not not invest in if you don't
have the marketing skills go to someone
like Lumi a consultant that can can help
you with the strategy so out of it if
you don't have the editing skills get
someone on instead of to the hack that
trailer cost is $300 because we have an
insanely cheap editor out of Holland who
just loves doing stuff for us when we
jet when we don't need you know creative
stuff we just need a good editor so it
doesn't have to cost a lot just don't
skimp I work across a range of different
development sizes and types of games and
trailers that I've worked on have cost
you know anywhere between 2,000 to
30,000 so there's a huge range out there
and it's just about finding something
that fits your project but making sure
that you actually do invest the time in
it whatever the resources are that you
have are make sure if you kind of best
financial resources doing best time
resources a lot of people talk about
costs on these things if you're making
an independent or if you're making some
that's commercial it's no longer costs
they're all investments right and then
you just need to look at every
individual investment as to its
potential return and I would argue that
trailers done well for the right game
have the highest return on invest the
other recommendation I'll make about
that is just make one good trailer
instead of four or five your average
trailers we mostly now just make the one
and we use it to announce the game and
it's also our launch trailer because
we've an indie game unlike to say I'm a
live-action kind of is an exception to
this rule most of the time there's not
that much more to say yeah
then you know people aren't coming to
learn about this particular feature that
you have to dedicate a trailer to they'd
just sell in the elevator pitch and so
if you make invest in one really good
trailer you do not need another one the
one you should invest in is the tonal
peace the gameplay trailer doesn't have
to be as slick because it's the second
trailer they watch on your store page
you know the other thing that you can do
which we've done for screen tea a lot
which we made let's play compilations
that press will not cover those because
it's competitive media basically but for
the store page it was a really good way
of showing that the game was fun but
also having validation so we we've been
screened she's been played by a lot of
big youtubers like PewDiePie and
markiplier and so on roosterteeth so by
putting together a compilation of
gameplay clips on them we've got not
just the gameplay but the reaction to
the gameplay and that when you watch
that as a consumer you go oh this game
is clearly fun and and I'm you know
excited by the gameplay and that's a
really most youtubers are very happy if
you just email them to use that content
so that can be a really good way to have
a good gameplay trailer which again is
just about an editing and editing job
cool we'll take question over here on
the right do you believe it is deceptive
marketing for a game company to use
pre-rendered footage and suggests that
it is actually in the game as gameplay
you know it's a really good question you
know obviously there's a it is always a
talking point you know when your trailer
comes out and it's like hey that's
exactly what the game is but but
recently you know that that's really
something to change you know game
engines are just getting so you know
[ __ ] hot in what they can put out and
how good the stuff looks that a lot of
people are going hey that's let's make
all of our marketing trailers in engine
using all the game assets I'm not sure
if any of you saw the Paragon trailer
for epic games did that's that's in
engine real time using the same assets
you're playing with in the game so well
you know that you know it's always gonna
be you know a marketing spin to go hey
look let's make something that's
complete eye candy that has nothing to
do with the game but we've all fallen
for it like if you go back in the day
you know one of plastic waxes first
trailers was a dawn attack that really
hit the market was Dawn of War 2 you
know that like pretty much every game
and knows that trailer but that that's a
top-down you know you know RTS when what
you're doing there is you're just making
you're making the magic and creating the
spark that is gonna excite all the
gamers right so I mean you know and then
people will come back and go hey that's
not the actual gameplay and and it's a
valid comment but I think as we move
forward you're gonna see a lot more
content that is actually because the
technology's there now in engine it's
exactly what it looks like but it but it
still looks feel like we're seeing sort
of as well that I think some companies
are picking up on you know on that kind
of sentiment that people are really
worried sometimes if it looks that good
and there's now you know they're
starting to use like oh yeah they'd
straight up riding on others like real
in-game footage to almost make that part
of the selling point of going no no
seriously this is this is in the game I
think I go so far as to say every
trailer is an ad if you're watching it
and you are not treating it like that
and applying a filter which is this is
an advertisement that's just crazy like
that's what they're there to do they're
not there to be here is 10 minutes of
gameplay exactly what the gameplay is
and now of Let's Plays and everything
else there are so many opportunities as
consumers to see the game as it really
is afterwards so treat trailers as ads
and be skeptical of what it is you know
they're not
they're not like here is just some
honest gameplay they are making the best
shot it kind of sell you the pitch of
the game right so I don't think anyone
should be looking at a trailer and kind
of feeling like they were conned into
thinking that's what the game was the
graphics are only one part of the game
as well it's like there's all this whole
other you know there's a story and the
music and the feeling that you get while
playing it and those are the things that
you also want people to feel when they
watch the trailer material as well so
it's not just about having like high
fidelity authentic graphics although
I'll tell you what mobile games adds I
was the worst conference of this all the
clash of clans oh yeah the other day I
was like playing like I don't know ten
thousand husbands or whatever I'm
playing on mobile at the moment and this
ad popped up and it was for a Dragon
game but it was so cool they were like
dragons sweeping over and I was like 3d
animated it's awesome awesome oh yeah
I'm gonna get this game I downloaded it
and I opened it and it was like cartoon
like really badly drawn 2d cartoon
dragon like clicker game and I'm like
how how this is not representative so
there's a line there that people need to
be aware of and I think like they are
sometimes taking advantage of you and
advantage of the fact that this is just
gonna get you to download the game but
yeah I don't think that's very fair
either well you're gonna put fully
pre-rendered and it's not even symbolic
of what the gameplay actually is then
that is completely I'm gonna I'm gonna
jump in there I'm gonna say that that's
not actually true what a what that is is
that's what we're talking about before
that's selling the dream and the reason
why I say those because we have a fully
2d animated game and none of those so
what we're doing because we are and it's
not deceptive I think the big thing with
this question or this general sentiment
is that people are out there - like -
like trap you or something like that
that's not the case people just want to
see they've been working on something
for four years or something they want
you to see it in the best light they're
so proud of it and also it's not it
doesn't come from maliciousness or a
melt like you know a bad intent or any
thing like that it's just people wanting
to show you something in the best light
and like Chris said it's an
advertisement they do want to sell the
game so they can continue making more
games and it's just this weird thing
where sometimes your desire for all you
know when I say you're I mean gamers in
general the public's desire for accurate
representation of what they're gonna buy
and then the developer or the publishers
desire to show you the best side of
something that they're incredibly proud
of and that they want to sell they just
get a little bit misaligned it's like
asking McDonald's to put up a real
photograph of a Big Mac you know or the
toy manufacturers within the toy ads to
like not fake how exciting that the toys
are all right its advertising is an
abstraction all advertising is an
abstraction and it's not documentary one
last question
ideology that perhaps people are
misleading consumers and stuff like that
is there anything when you're showing
people the trailer people are coming up
to you and saying don't show this don't
show that instead of please show this
it's really cool please show this aspect
you can't play is there anything that
people are saying please do not show
this less people overanalyze it and take
away 100 percent how director and my
business partner tie is just like do not
get that [ __ ] close to the models
they're not designed for that because
they're backwards in the game you know
but of course like we're not gonna shoot
up on the gate like you could do a
really cinematic shot of bran like one
about their characters like swing around
in but then you see out of the world or
something like that like definitely
those technical glitches also our Melo
is a game where you click and the
character moves click character moves
and you go car spelling goes but our
trailers like [ __ ] boom you know
what's going on if we just showed
gameplay what no one would buy our game
but it's not because the games play
sucks it's because in that format of a
two minute trailer it doesn't do it
justice it doesn't give you the feeling
that you have when you're at that
18-minute mark of a 90 minute epic game
of armello with your friends from across
well when people watching trailers have
no attention span right so a lot of
games you actually have to play for a
couple of hours before you get it yeah
something like one star until you have
to play for 20 hours before you get it
right so you cut yeah
adds a whole extra challenge right so
much in the attention span of what
people have you don't have the time to
explain stuff fully so you have to like
leave some of that stuff now we've all
well we had to leave out a lot of them
we had to really watch for spoilers
because the story driven thriller game
so we had to really be careful about
what we showed of the gameplay there was
another reason why we didn't have a lot
of gameplay in there that we didn't want
to have too many screens that people
could then start reading and trying to I
guess some of the plot beforehand so
that's I think for even for like CGI
games and so on again same thing you
don't want to spoil some of the story
elements of of games but you at the same
time you you want to show like the
exciting moments right so that becomes a
challenge too yeah well one of the risks
that happened happens quite a lot is you
you might have this great aspirational
trailer captures the magic in the tone
of the of the game and the client is
like okay there's this feature where
they upgrade if you do this can you have
to show that in the trailer or although
let's add that we want it we want to
show this unique thing we that they can
share our abilities or whatever and it's
like okay now let's just start
shoehorning that stuff in and that can
sort of really start to weaken the
message people don't sort of lose sight
hey we have this really great vision we
all agreed to it and then they just go
they start watering it down by trying to
you know jam stuff in there do you
remember hearing that the I'll be like
overwatch story videos that they've done
that they were quite pleased with they
in each of them each character uses
there are a set of abilities yeah and
their ultimate in some way to try to
have that kind of game attachment to
what is a total kind of little story
package yeah 100% and I think as well
like just for everyone in the room I
like really just give people the benefit
of the doubt at the end of the day like
when these people are making these
trailers they just want you to get into
their game they just they've been
working on something for however long
they want you to love it there are a
team of very talented people doing the
best they can
no one's there going ah he if they see
that they'll buy this game [ __ ] sucks
it's not even in the game
like you do actually have to be careful
with the trailer not to mislead people
too much steam has a steam refunds has a
category for the reason why you've
refunded that is specifically the
trailer doesn't match the game so what
you do actually and isn't either you do
have to think about how you're pitching
it because people don't spend as much
time thinking about whether they're
going to buy an indie game as they do a
triple-a game so it's more of an impulse
purchase
so in fact like there is an incentive
for us not to go too far off with the
message because we can then have
negative reviews you know and so on
it's like a free-to-play game then and
you download the game and it's not what
the trailer shows you're just gonna
delete it
yeah so you're not actually gonna get to
the point that you want which is people
engaging with your product that's on
irony about that clash of clans trailer
it's like you all you've lost is memory
that you can get back on your device
right like and if you've bought
something in the game then that has
nothing to do with the trailer that has
you going into the game and knowing
what's there and buying something Oh
could we give a very big thank you to
Katie's friend Chris Mick can see that
thank you very much
you